I think we're going to do some stuff on
vectorization today.
Welcome.
Uh, let me think
So, we had uh this thing, if I recall
correctly,
we had this weird bug where double
buffered training didn't work.
So, I think I'm just going to bite the
bullet today. And um
Welcome, Pepe. I think I'm just going to
bite the bullet today and I'm going to
work on some more dedicated tests for
this
Right. So this is what we had before.
This is just a performance test.
So I think what we want
we probably need to make like a test
environment.
Well, we can start with breakout though,
can't we?
Yeah, I think we can totally start with
uh with breakout here
and then I think that the only goal I
will have today Oh, actually I have to
check one thing to make sure I don't
have um
important emails. Yes.
Uh I have email I was expecting but I
don't have uh I don't have to do
anything immediately. So we can work on
this for today.
So, I think that the the plan here.
Yeah, we should actually totally just go
to
Let's see what is uh what is required
from this um
ocean
squared squared.h
we can pretty much just take all of this
stuff
and then I think we can minimize it
right.
Yeah. Yeah. This is what we're going to
do. We're just going to hardcode in. So
this will be a test environment.
Uh it doesn't need any of these
real metrics at all.
We'll just do absolutely minimal
template here.
I believe we're using float actions
right now and uh float obs.
Yeah. So we can totally just do this
and then intine
Yeah. So, I'm just going to basically
make a super dummy env. And we're going
to start using this for correctness
checks and then we'll use it for Perf
checks afterwards because basically
we'll make an M that has zero overhead
and uh we can use this to test max
throughput and whatnot. That'll be good.
I don't know why I'm so tired. My gosh.
I thought I was well rested and I went
for my uh my morning run.
Like decent but not super hard pace
and got all my exercise in yesterday.
It's just the uh getting close to the
holidays. Kind of think I'm just
implicitly expecting a break.
All right. So, where is
where are allocations for this?
Oh, we need to define
I see. So,
What do you do with day off?
About 50 sets yesterday.
I can barely move my uh my arms. Super
sore.
Uh I actually it's so far so good, man.
And some of the things that I thought
were limitations,
uh, George Hotz actually replied and
you, it turns out that you can actually
do a lot of the things I wanted to do.
It's just not documented. So, the plan
is that I'm going to work on this right
now and we're going to do more stuff
with Tiny Grad because it's actually
still pretty promising.
this need anything?
I think so.
admittedly that was very easy, right?
This is just super dummy. And
test ends.
Test ends.
Yeah.
That sounds good.
Hey Ratwag,
welcome.
unde use of undeclared identifier.
What?
How did I break false?
Am I dumb?
I didn't think you needed
thought that was built in.
So this is the exact same thing as
breakout
uh in sizes, but it's not doing any
work.
Ah, look at this. We have 45 mil SPS.
Cool.
This number is going to have to go
higher, I think. Uh, though, actually,
hang on. That's pretty good, isn't it?
Because if you do 45 mil,
is the OB size times four.
Yeah, that's 20 gigs. Uh that is 21 gigs
per second of memory transfer
and uh I think the max is 32
like the max possible is 32. We're
actually now we are above 50% efficiency
for the first time in the history of RL.
Get rid of this bot. What were things
Geo told were possible after the fact?
The main one is variable size shapes and
kernels. So if we can just get this
thing to generate as kernels that have
variable size uh variable sizes, that
helps me a lot.
That really helps me a lot.
Push N back to being bottleneck.
No. Uh actually because the thing is
vectorization is going to is going to uh
cut a lot of the end overhead.
So we're optimizing everything, man.
Honestly, there's very little
uncertainty left in the uh the new
update. Like I pretty much know
everything we need to do. It's just like
a lot of work and I'm kind of tired. So,
the goal is to kind of carve out a
couple chunks of this before I have to
take at least several days off, you
know, over the holidays
um and recharge and then come back and
do more stuff.
Like realistically, I should have just
taken a week off like probably two weeks
ago by now, but I've kind of wanted to
keep getting some stuff done.
But I've just like kind of taken a night
off here, a night off there, kind of a
thing.
I mean, I also I just want to have
things capped off so I can actually rest
when I decide to. Probably next week
sometime I'll take some time
See the thing that's difficult is I
don't think you can get access
and vec has m star m is this fully
defined.
That's let me actually check
um
pointer to incomplete type. Yeah. So
this is what we need to fix uh figure
out.
So, it's not going to be defined in the
header.
Can I get the type information? You
can't get the type information from the
DLL though is the thing cuz that's not
comp time.
This is Yeah, this is the downside of
doing this via DLS.
I'm probably going to come up with
something eventually not requiring this
though. I don't know. There are nice
sides to this as well.
Well, we can still get access to
observations, right?
Latest fitness article on X if you'd
like to know the reasoning behind that.
There are a bunch of people at NERS I'd
like to talk to this year, but
I'll stay here.
Ob size. Wait,
you don't even get this, do you?
Uh or
nah. That's lame as [ __ ] dude.
Not my style.
Okay, so
now we have the ability to do some form
of benchmarking at the very least,
right?
I don't think if there's an easy way to
number these.
What first got you into RL?
Um, I mean it was really around the era
of the Atari results. I started RL like
when pretty much all the new stuff was
coming out and then it was a combination
of that and then like seeing MMOs as
this new target.
uh and kind of like seeing RL as a
fundamentally different approach to
intelligence
and one that like works really really
well with games
and like you know using games to advance
intelligence in a really interpretable
and natural way.
Okay, that is everything here.
Um,
really like to number to number these
ends,
you know.
Wait, I totally can.
You dummy.
First deep mind results. No, I haven't
watched thinking game. Um,
originally it was Atari. Yeah.
and go. Atari and Go. And then the thing
that was like that really really got me
excited was Dota.
I still think Dota is the best result
the Field's ever gotten.
It's kind of becoming one of those
nuclear fusion things, right, where like
we have not had a better result since
2019.
That's definitely going to be one of the
goals I have with Puffer is to get a
better result than Dota.
I'm trying to think what would qualify.
A full MMO would definitely qualify.
It's tough because in my mind like even
a really useful result is not
necessarily the more technically
impressive one. Let's see.
They never really they training cost for
Dota. I mean you can estimate it right.
It was a thousand GPUs for a couple
months and then the big one was a
100,000 uh 50 or 100,000 CPU cores.
That was for the final training run and
you know they were using more than that
for development presumably.
It's not a lot of money by today's
standards in AI though.
The thing it was a lot of money for back
then
just the quality of techniques or
quality training data.
I'll just let the Dota AI guys play with
and simulate the same amount of go to
Dooms. Yeah, that's what they did.
The thing is, it's like
Dota is such an impressive problem to
solve and for all of the right reasons.
Yeah, it wouldn't cost as much now. It
would still be expensive, but
but the thing is like the majority of
the training costs for that thing are
because the game is expensive to
simulate, right?
Like you can totally implement Dota to
be a hundred times faster than it is.
Like games are never optimized anywhere
near the uh the extent that is possible.
Okay, I'm trying to think what I want to
do with this. I don't want to just be
waffling around here.
do like this? Two buffers,
four threads,
16 environments
of
32 like this.
This will be ve on.
There's the guy Otar who said that he
got um it was kind of funny. He said
that he got like super fast
uh Game Boy emulator
uh but then he was profiling it wrong.
So we'll see if he comes back and
actually gets something fast. But yeah,
pretty much any any emulator that you
would get. I don't even think you can do
an emulator to be fair. I think you'd
have to like nativeize stuff, but um
anything that would get you access to a
large number of games at at least
100,000 steps per second. Uh ideally,
you'd want it to be more than that,
though. Uh yeah, that would unlock a
lot. The problem is it's actually it's
very difficult to think of anything
where you could get access to a bunch of
games that run at that level of PF. Like
you're pretty much limited to very old
games, stuff like Game Boy games, and
then like um the problem is writing an
emulator that is that fast is hard. But
I don't know I don't know actually what
else you would do. Um I don't know if
it's possible to like nativize those
things automatically.
But yeah, like that type of stuff is
really awesome. And the thing is the
perf targets can just get higher and
higher and higher.
EBA games built in C natively.
I mean, they're built for the thing is
they are built for the hardware, right?
It's developed for cartridge, man.
kind of a miracle. Um, like the thing is
those those games were something of a
miracle if you think about it. How hard
developing for cartridges.
You have games that are like still fun
to play
um like three decades.
Three decades. Yeah. Literally three
decades later.
19.
Yeah. Three decades later.
And they were like just perfect on
release. No ability to patch or
anything.
if somebody has done it fast
like it has to be by somebody who
actually understands the PF targets of
RL, right? Like it's so much higher than
you would do normally. And it's not even
it's not unrealistic at all. Like you
can totally make games run that fast.
They actually aren't doing that much
logic. You have to be thinking of it.
I mean, I guess we can just start with
Yes.
I don't know what this egg p thing is
about, but we'll get to that. Um,
so
let's now go check
our test end.
Okay, perfect. Now we actually have a
viable test, right?
Okay, we still get an error, right?
I still get an error.
where you base?
No, seasonally. I move around
seasonally. I'm in Maryland at the
moment. Welcome to the puffer training
facility. I do spend some time in the
summer um
in uh in California though
doing float for ve two. Are you not
doing float
for vec 2?
You're reusing um
you're reusing the pointer, right?
I mean this is expected to be wrong
because our training is wrong at the
moment. So
now let's see if this does anything
first.
this one is also Well, that's actually
No, that's expected. Hang on.
I'm trying to think how I want to do
this.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Excend.
This is one got to be one.
There we go.
Got it.
So according to this
uh we pass the CPU sync test.
Ah, look at this.
So, it's failing with threading on.
I was testing with no threading and this
actually passes.
I mean, I wouldn't say I'm exactly
fresh, but let's see. Um, let's see if I
can spot anything now. I have stepped
away from it for a bit.
I got stuck on this uh this bug on
Saturdays.
Okay, so we called create environments
like this 8192 m right
zero threads.
So num ends zero threads
last year master student working on
medical AI
regression. Uh you don't use you don't
use RL for regression. You use RL for
interaction tasks. So it really depends
on your problem.
RL is not the solution to everything.
It's just the current solution to many
things that I'm thinking about that's
being like very much overlooked
elsewhere.
Typically for RL you want a problem that
requires interact a lot of interaction
and a problem for which you can have a
very fast simulator.
Try this. Thanks. Happy coding. Thank
you.
Yeah. So, it doesn't look like this
works.
This is about the result we were getting
before from the broken version.
That's non-trivial learning, but it's
not good either.
I mean, this is telling me that I have
these identical
except with this, but I have zero
threads. So, like we should start with
that.
I mean, is it possible that after all I
just do have some dumb thing broken in
um
I really don't see anything wrong with
this, man.
the single threaded one is completely
synchronous, right?
VEX size
divided by vec buffers.
Yeah, this is the entire thing
and vec receive doesn't do anything
with um
the single threaded version.
I mean this literally this the entire
code
device to host.
Get your actions right.
Back actions start.
Let's
Let's try this DLL test thing again. Um,
we're going to try
Yeah, this is what we're going to do
this time. different.
That doesn't do anything. That's weird.
Why does that not do anything?
There should be a way I can set these
actions now.
I don't have access to CUDA functions in
here.
the shared library.
That seems odd.
Paddle doesn't move.
That seems odd to me.
Oh,
hang on. This needs to be
breakout.
Well, that's interesting. This does get
compiled.
you end up requesting that username.
Yeah, I don't know why they denied it
actually. Thank you for reminding me.
Uh, okay. I'm not doing this on stream.
I literally I already did this stupid
thing.
Good job, X. I already did that,
but I will go do that again off stream.
I'm super annoying.
Oh yeah, I ordered one of these and I it
has not showed up yet.
I ordered one of these more than a month
ago. Like where's my phone?
Minimal mean they're shipping it by
carrier pigeon?
even a carrier pigeon would have been
here by now.
Might have have to be two carrier
pigeons carrying it together on a
string.
Okay, wait. We have some other options
here to debug. I'm kind of just being
slow today.
That's very weird.
Back actions.
Am I doing this wrong? What?
we go. Looking up the docks of Mems set.
See if I've gone insane.
you dummy. Cuz I forgot that it's not.
Okay, let's do it this way.
Still no. Oh no. We're good now. It's
moving.
GPU action to start value.
Try this.
See, we're just trying to make sure that
actions are getting processed and [ __ ]
Okay, this is good. So,
uh I'm not going insane. Actions are
getting processed here. We see
you set actions in here, they do get
propagated.
Oh, unless hang on. Unless I'm being
dumb.
No, we're still good. Let me see.
And I can just set this to like one, for
instance,
Okay, so actions are being correctly
propagated.
I'm trying to think what other sources
of error we could even have or what test
I can even write
cuz I have the other test passing.
This code works with one buffer but not
with two.
Let's actually go double check that I
didn't break that real quick.
Yeah. So we can see immediately
way way way better, right?
If we have um two buffers
I would suspect that the error then is
in here, right?
I didn't want to. So, yep. This is
expected
is expected.
H
bus.
I'm trying to think what type of error
could possibly get caused by
having two buffers here instead of one.
Eight.
Cool.
Is that answer one thing?
What the heck could this possibly be
screwing up? Um,
it's either here or it's in the end,
right? And I've tested the end. I think
the end is fine.
I have it exactly the same way. I don't
see how you could be breaking the
indexing here, though, either. Oh, yeah.
I opened Discord because Jess had
something, didn't
like threads calicers? I didn't think
so. Right.
Which in this case is num ms.
Yeah. So it's cal to num ms
float float float. Yeah, that's fine. N
agents
correct.
Trying to look for a specific algo
global potential field optimizer. So
it's non-local.
We can ignore local minima. The [ __ ]
No, you don't have global optimization
algorithms. Those do not exist.
I don't know what you mean by potential
field though.
Back receive doesn't take H. Huh?
What do you mean?
Did I miss Did I miss something?
No, it would take the buffer index. H is
the current time step.
Buff is the index of the buffer. So you
alternate back and forth between
buffers. I also for context, right, I
wrote this test to make sure I was not
screwing anything up. And this passes
this thing here. So I made it with uh
zero threads with one buffer and with
two buffers, which is what I'm doing
here. I reset both of them. I set them
the obs. I initialize the obs the same.
And then the the step actually just
increments all the obs by one.
And then this passes, right? So this one
gets received every other because it's
buffered. This one gets received all at
once.
You go through the current block and you
check they're all equal.
This is stepping the
uh yeah, this is stepping the buffered
one or the uh the sync one and then this
is the buffered one. So this passes,
which leads me to believe I'm not doing
anything completely stupid here, though.
I mean, this is admittedly a fairly
brittle test.
Like, what else would I be screwing up
though?
Okay. So there you go. Size of actions.
This is correct,
right? 32K
cuz it's times 8.
Uh, this is CUDA
Malik
try something like this
cuz I guess technically it could be
something weird with that.
Yeah. See, this one just gets stuck at
like 20s.
There's no single point of failure.
Well, it's weird because I have a test
that basically says that this matches
the single thread uh the single buffer
version,
but somehow it doesn't train. So,
I don't know what to do about that.
I swear if this ends up being some C++
[ __ ] I'm going to be so mad.
Yeah, I'm just baffled by this.
I'm trying to think what else I can do.
I guess we have to do this. We have to
just invest more in this test.
Pain in the ass, but I don't know what
else to do.
Two M's
threads, two buffers.
Uh, well, hang on. And now they share
RNG.
Damn it.
Yeah, they're going to share RNG. That's
annoying.
Ooh. Okay.
Okay. I like this.
We take There was just one little bit of
randomness in there.
Okay. So, I mean, now we have a complete
test
that says that with these settings,
which are exactly what we're using
um
at every single step, these buffers are
the same.
That's what we have.
[sighs] I guess we're not inputting any
actions, though.
There's one other thing I want to try
there.
No, not really. Actually, I had it
right.
Uh,
Anybody
have any ideas?
I'm all ears right now.
What the hell's going on?
Like, what haven't I checked?
It's literally the same thing.
Literally the same thing.
It's got to be something in Pupper then,
like the the C++ here, right?
I don't know what the hell it would be,
but
One tripper was still being called.
Shouldn't be
This is just such a bizar bizarre bug to
me. Like, I'd understand if I had bugs
and threading, sure, and I would be able
to do stuff, but like when there's no
room for there to even be anything
wrong, what the [ __ ] do I do?
Like, what the heck
is something just getting silently
copied and just [ __ ] with me? Is that
it? I can't think of anything else other
than Torch just being a piece of [ __ ]
and like silently making a copy here
somewhere
but like stuff is getting copied in
otherwise it would be zero reward
or not zero episode it would be like
eight I think eight seven or eight is
the highest you get randomly
I'm trying to think like what other test
I can even write.
I've literally written this code
for the stepping of the end, right, with
breakout
and it works flawlessly. It's like every
bite is the same.
This is alternating exactly as you'd
expect.
Okay.
Narrow.
Return tensor and input share the same
underlying storage.
I literally synchronized the device
though
and there's no custom streams.
whole thing is super simple.
Like there's
going to drive me nuts. It was like how
right
I'm trying to think what else I can even
what what else can I do to figure this
out.
What's the bug? I'm running this with
zero threads. So, literally, it's just
running this block.
And uh for whatever reason, this works
with one buffer and it doesn't work with
two buffers.
Like, the thing doesn't learn. And I
literally have a test that it's the
exact same everything with one buffer or
two buffers as well.
It's weird.
It's driving me nuts as well.
There's nothing in train, right?
Depends on this.
There really should not be, right?
Yeah, we actually there's going to be
some good stuff from Tiny. I'm probably
going to do that stuff tomorrow. I just
really want to fix this bug today and
this is driving me nuts.
just like so incredibly painful to
figure this out.
I I don't even know what test I could
write that would be better either.
I guess it's worth doing this with
actions.
And the thing that drives me nuts about
this is this is supposed to be the easy
one. Like there's the threading [ __ ] to
fix after this. Like why is this hard?
This is supposed to be [ __ ] trivial.
I'm so limited as well in what I can
even do to debug. The whole C++ harness
is horshit. Um,
You know what I what else I can do?
Let me test. There's actually there is
something I can do. Yeah, there's
something I can do to test.
Okay, hear me out on this one.
We're going to make We're going to
create the environments.
We're going to keep one buffer.
Okay,
I thought of something.
Let's keep one buffer here.
Um but
going to do if
you're going to receive here
and then we're going to do over here.
That make sense?
I think that makes sense.
This should isolate whether it's in the
C++
or in the end of code
definitively.
This will actually be good.
I'm glad I thought of that.
How the [ __ ] is that going to seg
instantly?
Does not make any sense, right?
Ah, I see. It's got to be received zero.
Hang on.
Let me get this.
This will be a good test.
Okay,
this still works. You see
this still works.
and actually that works that full solve
so we know it's actually fully correct
as well.
So that's okay. Perfect. Good. I can
work with this.
Okay, so we're going to do both vec
receives here
and we're going to do both vex sends
here and we're going to see if that
changes it. Okay,
Dang.
Growth on this has been nuts.
This does not solve everything like
before.
So this index and code is right.
Somehow
use of two buffers is bad.
But we're not going to use these
anyways.
Threads is zero.
Okay,
so far so good.
Back reset
back size gets set to nums, right? Yes.
Hello, Jess.
like to the size of the threads.
Oh, that's zero.
Oh, wait. That's zero.
There should be buffers.
that seriously gonna
that would change anything because
we use this
now. See, this is still broken.
Okay, but let's just um
kind of careful here.
This one's fine, actually. There's
nothing in there.
Okay. So, now you're going to go to vec
buffers. Hang on.
Ve buffers is buffers, right?
All right, I need a few minutes and then
um we will continue. I need a few
minutes. This is driving me nuts. Don't
let me forget to unmute my mic.
And I forgot to unmute the mic.
Hang on, Liberty. I'll respond to that
in a minute. Me go. Uh, is this hot?
Could be hotter. One minute.
you uh typically you don't want to
render the game at all if you can avoid
it because rendering is slow.
And well, at least on the scale of
things that we'd like to run, rendering
is slow. And even if you do render it,
now you have image observations, which
typically require a little stack of coms
to process, which is also slow. Uh you
don't ever need it at a huge resolution.
One of the nice things about
uh about rendering is you kind of
eliminate the problem of having a really
complicated observation space,
but you pay a lot for that. Like you're
going to pay probably a factor of a
hundred in perf. Like tens of thousands
of steps per second is typically max we
see.
And then with threading, I've seen like
up to 150k maybe.
But it's still not great and it doesn't
like it's really not what you'd like
ideally. Now, if you have something
where you actually make that faster and
you can get up to a couple hundred
thousand steps per second per GPU
without consuming all the cores on a
multi-GPU machine, that's another story.
But we kind of just have not invested in
uh in doing that yet. And that's quite
hard to do in general.
Uh, I think ob spaces,
the thing is that like ob spaces become
pretty tough.
I'd kind of rather solve the obspace
problem anyways because the action space
problem is still there, right? Like you
still have to design your environment
for a a reasonable action space even if
you render. So, it doesn't just solve
all your problems and it's a bunch of
engineering. Uh there's no there's like
no fundamental difference from like
training from pixels being better or
more general either. That's kind of just
like an academic stupid thing.
How did OpenAI do it? They did not
render on they did not train on pixels.
They had state access and they could run
tons and tons of instances of the game.
the reason that the uh Game Boy emulator
is relevant is because like older games
had really [ __ ] hardware, right? So the
idea is that if you run a old game on
modern hardware, maybe it's actually
going to be pretty fast. Um but then the
thing is like the older games weren't
designed for PCs, at least not a lot of
them. They were designed for uh for like
handheld consoles, so you have to run
them through an emulator and then making
the emulator fast is tricky as well.
But yeah, there's a whole bunch of
stuff, frankly.
Whole bunch of stuff.
All right, let's fix this freaking bug.
Let's go.
We have some more info at the least.
Oh.
Oh, come on.
Am I that stupid,
dude?
The [ __ ] is wrong with me, man?
What is wrong with me?
Apologies for the delay on the
vectorzation back end, folks. I am a
[ __ ] [ __ ] as it turns out.
Well, this is one of those bugs where
like how happy I would be at fixing this
is balanced out by how [ __ ] stupid I
feel for missing this for so long.
I'm actually even surprised the LM's
missed that one. That one is super
obvious.
That's just me being a [ __ ] goober.
This is why you don't write code when
you're tired.
Like, it just takes longer to debug it
than it did if like I just wrote it
fresh,
honestly.
Yeah, I was just indexing some random
ass starting address in observations
that the completely wrong address.
I guess having um
having like multi-dimensional
having like nice syntax for
multi-dimensional arrays
uh dynamically allocated
would be really nice and see
there's a way to do it. It's just really
obnoxious
there.
Well, at least we finish this with at
least uh a couple more hours to do some
real work. Yes, that was literally it.
That was the thing that I spent like
five hours looking for. I almost never
do that where I spend five hours looking
for something that stupidly simple. I
don't even know, man. I need a vacation.
What is your longest training time?
Like a week on six GPUs.
But that's kind of a dumb way to measure
scale, right? Because it's like
if you look at the number the amount of
data we process or the number of steps
we train or stuff like that like we've
made puffer so fast that a one machine
training run can actually do a lot of
work right so
I mean another way of saying that is
that we trained on 12,000 years worth of
gameplay and we've done that three or
four times at this All right.
Stupid bug.
That's such a stupid bug.
Well, now we can go uh we can go look at
other stuff, I think. Um
at least this did make us at least right
this did make us write a decent test.
which we will now benefit from.
I'm going to comment out this randomness
here.
Um, yeah, I'm going to comment this
randomness.
No, this should me this should be fine.
Oh, let me reply. I have one client
message to look at.
Are the demos on the puffer website
results from fully trained models? Uh
yes, with some small limitations. We
actually we discovered a bug in the
deployment code that can screw up the
policies to some extent or another. So
some of these are pretty much exactly as
they're trained. Some of these could be
substantially worse. But yeah, you do
have all the demo models on the site.
These are running live in your browser
as well. These are not videos. Like
here, I can hold shift. Where is it?
Yeah, now I'm playing, right? And then
from any point I can just let go and the
agent will take over.
It's pretty fun. Oh yeah, for folks
watching, what are you doing? Star the
puffer. If you have not starred the
puffer, help me out. It's free. It's
absolutely free. We don't like it when
the curve goes concave. We like convex.
We like convex optimized puffer.
Got to keep feeding the puffer so it
gets bigger.
We have a fair few folks on Twitch
today. I don't know what happened with
discoverability. Usually I have
everybody on YouTube. I probably should
like figure out how to do the Twitch
branding and stuff correctly, but
because I launched the stream from
reream, like there's no way to set a
category from there.
A little annoying.
Okay. Um,
next thing we're going to run this
tests.
And now we do threads.
We see if it passes with the reds.
interesting.
Oh, no. It's not interesting. You dummy.
Commented a line and then you forgot
about it.
Yeah. Yeah, we can totally get a version
of this to work today. That'd be nice.
Let me make sure I get this correct
though. You want one stream per buffer,
not one stream per thread, right?
Atomic store.
Okay, this is fine. So, this is the one
that we wanted, right? Atomic store.
This atomic store right here needs to be
set up.
Boom. Okay, cool.
Now we have an actual genuine failure to
look at
presumably.
It's interesting though that it passes
the first 200.
Let me go double check this thing for
errors again.
What did we allocate here?
This is now correct.
You in you create these
threads plus one, right? You make one
extra thread.
And then what do we do in vec reset? Vec
reset synchronous still cuz we're lazy.
restore this buffer.
This is sent
and on receive
there's receive.
Right. And we probably have the same
stupid bug
up here, don't we? The the thread
manager.
Hey, look at this. Same stupid bug.
That
This need to be here too, doesn't it?
Start times
obsidi
rewards terminals?
What about actions? Where's act where
actions get copied and send right? Did I
do this correctly? Yes, I did.
Boom.
Loads.
Uh, does this work for
zero threads?
Oh, and we see that it actually got way
farther that time, which is interesting.
So, it's very random.
right? We can just try uh synchronous
copies.
Okay, we are still failing.
We have no async in this entire file.
Yep, it'll fail. Okay. Uh, that's
interesting.
Evening. Hello, Tim.
We fixed the um
no thread. We fixed the zero thread or
like the main thread vers uh based
version of this. It was a really stupid
bug. Now I'm fixing the much more
complicated version of this.
head is fuzzy when I'm doing [ __ ] like
this. Come on. There we are.
4096. Perfect. Look, you see this is
what I wanted.
Let's like unfuck this
syntax here.
So this is threaded but all the
transfers are synchronous
So if actions are ready on the CPU
broadcast to wake up
add
end index to block size
Block size plus.
So this is you've completed a block,
right?
Where's threading start index get
updated?
right here.
And there's only one of these threads.
So this should be safe, right?
So what do we get? We get work index,
completed index, end index,
something like that. Yeah, work done. So
start index just a regular variable.
This gets added block size.
Start.
Now we have to make sure we did this
correctly.
Start is
done. Buff. What the heck is this?
now we'll have to make sure that's
correct.
All right, I just have some messages I
had to answer.
Um,
The main thing I can think of is messing
up the um the indexing
of like job completion in here, right?
as you add the block size in. Whoops.
This is always an increment of block
size.
You only ever increment the completed
index when it's actually completed.
index.
Wouldn't you just do this while
completed index
is less than?
Hang on. What if I do completed
decks?
Okay. So,
what do I do?
Uh,
what do we do? What do we do?
frankly a lot of stuff. Oh, yeah. We
were going to check the uh the done
buffer thing, right?
Not atomic load operating on CPU and
then we synchronize.
Fine.
That's totally fine.
Okay. Other than that, let's see.
Reset
This is fine either way.
To host.
Yep.
Ready on GPU
stored.
Broadcast
on false
If complete is greater than equal block
size plus
then they're ready on the CPU. All
right.
brain is not braining right now.
I'm trying to think what else I should
just be checking other than just staring
at this.
So, I mean, we really only test a way
simpler path with this no thread
version.
Oh, you know, why am I being Am
I being like this, right? I should just
do
here.
Yeah, there's there's just dumb stuff
that's not clicking with me right now,
right? Like, why the hell am I not just
doing this?
Okay.
So this is the
threaded version, right?
This is our threaded version.
Good.
Yes. Good.
Happy.
Full buffs.
Yeah.
Okay. So, it's the buffered one that's
screwed.
interesting that that happens.
But it's cool though that uh even the
threaded version, it seems like it works
and it it matches with um
with a bunch of threads. So, it's just
the buffering somehow.
Me think how that would be. I mean, it
could just be something similar to what
I had before, right?
Let's go hunting for stupid [ __ ] that I
could have broken.
Two buffers.
We already tested this.
yeah,
girl.
Let me think if there's some interle
[ __ ] here.
Processing as soon as actions
are ready on GPU, right?
I may like Tai Chi lang.
No,
bad Tai Chi.
[snorts]
That's funny.
It's got to be something with this
concurrency, right?
The fact that um
Wait, hang on.
Let's just make sure I'm not being a
dummy.
Start and end.
No, this is correct, right? I just want
to make sure I'm not getting my test
itself wrong. A really dumb way to be
wasting time.
Well, because that's not this channel,
man.
By the time I'm tired enough to boot up
a game, I can promise you it's going to
be even less interesting than watching
me get stuck on a bug for four hours.
I don't even think my brain has the
energy to commentate stuff, Pepe. And I
really want this thing to be done
because like
this thing is gating me from doing a
whole bunch of other stuff basically.
And I don't think it's going to get
better for the next like week. I think
it's pretty much just like finish this
and then pretty much everything else I
have to do for the rest of the week is
easier than this.
Indie games. I'm currently been playing
Evan uh Evans Shore. It's like this
single player MMO by a single dev and
it's pretty awesome.
I wonder if
there anything we can get printed.
It's all going to be async, right?
I mean, it's a combination of me like
being tired, but also this is actually
kind of genuinely hard.
Um, this is a non-trivial threading
architecture.
You've got the main thread, you've got a
manager thread, and then you've got a
whole bunch of these worker threads. And
there are also all of these are passing
GPU buffers back and forth.
So,
it's not very much code, but there's
actually a fair bit going on There.
Wait,
hang on.
OB's ready. No, I don't think so. I'm
not I'm not depending on the stream
here, am I?
Hang on. Let me just make sure I'm not
depending on the stream.
Wait, OBS ready on CPU.
Wait, OBS ready.
Let me see what order I do this in.
these copies here
are synchronous.
So these obs are ready
on the CPU.
They're also ready on the GPU.
So like
this waits for everything to be done.
This doesn't do anything, but it doesn't
matter.
comic load.
These are bulls, right?
actions are ready.
Dream is synchronized.
Going to add the end index to this or
the block size.
Wake up the threads
and call store.
If this were sinking wrong, it would
just hang. It wouldn't
It wouldn't be wrong. It would just
hang.
And then you do atomic load on the
completed index.
It has to be greater than block size
plus start index.
Verdict. Uh there's some use for it. I
believe E10. We're going to do another
stream probably tomorrow on it.
a lot of the stuff that I wasn't sure
about. Um, apparently it exists. It just
wasn't documented like where it was
obvious.
I'm going to go back through tomorrow.
being developed by three people. Is it
actually three? Is it like three plus
all the open source stuff?
Do you need a GPU to contribute
meaningfully to Puffer Lib? Um, no, not
at all. Like, you can still develop
environments and stuff. And actually, if
you've built a couple environments that
work well, you'll get access to GPUs
from us anyways.
That's funny. Well, I mean, if they end
up do making something better than Torch
and Jacks, like how funny is that going
to be?
I mean, Puffer Lib is this and um we are
100 to a,000x faster than everything
else out there.
also being simpler and less code.
And that's with you see me spending half
the time being stuck on dumb stuff as
well.
Jack is 300 people. Yeah. And it's ass
use on my library when I make one if
it's good.
You guys have a low price GPU to
recommend?
Not really. I mean, we use like our
machines are um they're cheap by data
center standards, but they're not cheap,
right? We just have like high-end
desktops.
You can train even on CPU a lot of our
simpler environments at like 100,000
steps per second, but on GPU, we can get
up to like 3 million. So
all the math stuff,
no it's just like
making a good tensor library is not easy
at all. You actually need to know what
the hell you're doing.
Oh yeah, also oh I thank you for
reminding me. Um so yeah, it's if you
want to like just train some stuff
faster. Yeah, like 30 cents an hour on
uh on vast
is pretty good because like you can
pretty much do all your dev on CPU and
even some of your smaller training bits.
Wake up other threads without a safety
lock.
Get stuck forever. Cool. The LLM is
[ __ ] stupid because uh it does not
hang. I would know exactly what to look
for if it were hanging. And
uh what's happening is we're getting
different data
with two instances of this. We're
getting different data
Then it botches things. Not an L.
Maybe another year. That's what they've
been saying for three years.
No more programmers in six months or a
year or whatever.
And then every single new model that
comes out, I try and it's [ __ ] And
everybody raves about how good it is.
And then I try it and it's like, you
know, it's eaten glue.
I'm trying to think what else can what
other tests can we run?
We should be able to come up with some
stuff, right?
Yeah.
Try this.
Okay, this is what we needed. I don't
know why I didn't try this before. I'm
tired, I guess. Let me just make sure
it's not just rarer.
Yeah, that looks good. So, it only
breaks with two threads
or more.
So, it's got to be then. I mean, the
only place
that uses the threads is right here.
Most people just don't have actual
meaningful engineering problems.
They haven't meaningful engineering
problems. They don't have meaningful
engineering talent for the most part.
Like a lot of it's like, oh well these
open AI researchers or these like Google
guys use it or whatever. It's like yeah,
have you seen scientists write code?
Like the ones who are good at it are
very effective but vast majority of um
like research scientists just have not
put any meaningful effort into learning
how to write good code.
You can kind of tell as well when people
are like really heavily relying on LLMs
for everything that they talk about
cuz like they mess up weird stuff,
right? Like it's like they have
superficial knowledge, but they mess
stuff up that like, you know, you you
shouldn't be able to be this confident
and knowledgeable about this thing
without knowing about this thing, right?
It's like stuff's out of order.
Okay, so we know the bug is right here
somewhere
with how we're sinking this ship.
This is everybody wake up
and then everybody grab some of this.
X less than end
up with some M's.
Ah,
you dummy. I see it.
Okay, I see it. Yeah, I see the error,
guys. So, it's if you have two threads,
um,
this completed index is not correct
because it can be adding stuff out of
order. I see it. This is actually an
architecture design oversight on my
part.
Let me go walk around for a couple
minutes and um
then I will consider how to patch Yes.
Okay,
here's going to be the deal, folks. It's
400 p.m. I'm tired. Um, I've been
banging my head against this all day,
but I understand the problem.
I'm going to explain this in a way that
makes sense. Even if you are not super
experienced with concurrency, all this
crap,
um,
y'all can give input on how to fix it.
We're going to figure this out in the
next hour. Then I'm getting dinner. I'm
going to get myself a nice glass of
wine. And I'm going to bed super early.
That is my plan for the rest of today.
So
here's the problem.
We have a bunch of environments, right?
And these environments need to get
updated, need to be stepped through. The
way that we do this is we have a whole
bunch of threads. and the threads are
supposed to be able to grab environments
as they come in and update them.
Um
so the problem is that right now uh work
has to be completed in blocks of say
2,000 environments.
Okay. And the way that we do this is uh
each thread is going to look at the
current index like what's needs to be
completed. It's going to safely in a way
that it's not fighting with the other
threads. It's going to say, "Okay, I'm
going to be responsible for uh this
environment and the next 256 of them or
whatever."
Okay. And then when it finishes that, it
says, "Cool, we the total number of
environments for which we've completed
work goes up by 256."
Uh so the problem is what can happen
right now is if you have multiple
threads
all checking out different blocks of
work. Uh you can have like thread zero
can check out 0 through 256
environments. Uh and then thread one can
check out 256 through 512 and so on and
so forth. And let's say that you
complete environment,
124 in environment in my example, let's
say you complete up to environment
uh before you've completed some of the
previous ones.
You can increment that index of
completed past the earliest environment
for which you haven't actually
completed.
So you actually want to track is what is
the index of the, you know, the earliest
environment that hasn't been completed
yet or whatever. Uh so when you go and
check, hey, are we done with this block
of environments? You've counted the
total number of environments completed,
but you have it wrong because they're
not the environments that actually need
to be completed. They can happen out of
order.
Yeah, that's my plan for the evening,
Pepe.
Um,
this is a design flaw.
Can't you just add account?
Account of what?
plus one when an environ Yeah. So, but
then then they can count out of order
because you can go like they can grab
work off the queue and the ones working
on the higher index environments can
finish first.
Track of processing buffers with a hash
function.
There's some difficulty because you're
also limited in the synchronization
primitives. But pretty much all I'm
using now is I have the ability to
increment or decrement a counter by
whatever value I like in a way that is
safe such that uh you know it's not
going to have two threads trying to do
it at the same time.
What you really want to know, I guess,
is the minimum index.
Let me see if I can reduce this problem
to something that's got to be standard.
Actually, this can be an LLM question.
I'm sure this is basic but I have to
frame it in a simpler like a standard
format. Um
threading problem
suppose you have array of
elements process
threads.
Now
Good job. State-of-the-art language
model that everybody spent
whatever amount of time on
It's not a simpler solution. It's just
wrong.
Uh I don't know if it helps. So you need
the counter to be how many duns or which
aren't returned. I don't know what we
need. I just know the constraints.
comic array.
Okay, so this thing's [ __ ] dumb.
How far ahead can it possibly get? Is
there any limit?
There's literally no limit on how far
ahead it can get, is there?
Hang on.
Let me see if I can get this problem
into a canonical form.
It is literally the thing that I just
wrote.
So counting up.
Come on. That can't possibly be You
can't possibly be telling me this is the
best way to do it, right?
No way.
How do you implement that? Actually,
you probably have to have um additional
synchronization.
Oh
yeah, this is not good.
Okay, it just like it this technically
solves the problem I gave it, but like
it just it hacked the test case
basically. Stupid thing.
Okay. Uh, what do we do? What do we do
with this
Yeah, but then you have to split your
work like you have to split your work
into a ton of chunks
and then you have to iterate over. It's
like very complicated.
There's got to be a better way to do
this. How the [ __ ] is there not um
Okay, I have an idea.
Let me frame this another way.
per buffer is not terrible though.
That's better than per block or per
thread.
So, we'll just do
here.
You write a recursive function. How the
[ __ ] does that make any sense, dude?
instead of looping through something
that's not remotely true.
Yes, but you're completely you're
completely misapplying that in a way
that makes absolutely no sense.
Like literally just try to write out the
full idea of like how recursion makes
this any makes any sense here like what
you would do step by step and you'll see
that it makes no sense.
Oh, what's that? Is that from Tim?
Oh, bon with puffer. Yo, you on stream,
Tim?
There's Tim, right?
Yeah, that's actually a really good M to
add. I don't know why I didn't think of
that one.
Look at um look at Tower Climb for some
examples. I think it'll be substantially
easier for you cuz the map gen is not
gigantic.
Um but yeah, so could be a really good
end.
Kingdom maps. How many maps they have?
Do they have a lot or is it like not
They have a lot. All right. If they have
a lot, then they have a lot.
There's an algo to make them hard.
Medium. Yeah.
Yep. Yep.
game logic pretty easy. Yeah, it's
actually the map gen is the only hard
thing, right?
Like Soaban literally the map gen is the
only hard thing.
was asked to be solvable and
interesting.
Mhm. That's fine, Tim. This will be a
good end.
I'd probably do partially observable.
Um,
just because otherwise you're going to
tank SPS.
So, I'd probably basically do it like
mazes where you get um 11 by1 11 window
11 by 11 window into eight like um you
only need like three or four channels
actually. You only need Wait, why do you
have boxes and oh holes?
Wait, is the goal to put the boxes on
the holes? Is that it?
10 by 10. Well, 10 by 10 doesn't make
sense, right?
Three.
Oh, the whole map. Okay.
That's annoying that you have four
things cuz otherwise it would be easy
easy to do 0gative one and one. But
okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Not not a problem, I'd say.
Very good. Maximum puffing.
Oh, this is a problem, too, though.
[ __ ]
I'm going to try something. I'm going to
try this again.
isn't this fine?
I think it's fine, isn't it?
Yeah, I think it's actually Wait, I can
I can salvage it.
Comic that
door.
I think I can get this to work.
Yeah.
This is still wrong.
God damn. Why is this so difficult?
Well, yep,
that's annoying.
I'm gonna have to go in uh 10 minutes,
folks. Um we'll see what I can do on
this. Uh but
just so I mention it, it's all open
source. Puffer AI. Star of the Puffer
helps me out. Discord for dev. Um X for
more RL content. Follow, etc., etc.
Let me see if I can figure this out in
the next 10 minutes.
It's like close. It should be at least
maybe. I think I just kind of need a
break
few days.
I'll take one soon, don't worry.
currently. Grabbing
that one.
They'll all be above the
lock index.
Weird.
Oh man, this is just weird.
Well, actually, it's always at the
boundaries now. That's interesting,
right?
Hang on. This might just be an off by
one.
Assembly level work. Not yet, Eric.
And I thought I had it. That definitely
made it more consistent.
How's that? Not
could be another bug to be fair.
Be weird.
Block size
plus
Oh, that should be fine.
The heck is wrong with it then?
I don't know what's wrong.
I'm going to call it, guys. I'm too
tired to do this now. Um,
I will be back tomorrow with tiny grad.
Might have to finish this. We'll see.